expedition in unbekannten schweizer
alltag habe ich ja ganz gab ein
schlimmer verdacht und zwar an ein dock
kollegen schmidt zu fernsehen mal den
reporter gemacht hat ist man dort ein
und zählt die krankheit ist offen
es gibt es tickets zwei buchstaben und
den kompass 260 kilometer genau wie
immer beim nach ob sie schon bald mit
girls andere bahnhof st
koffer packt trendy darf sie nicht
brauchen und ich mussten allesamt wieder
ein szenario prinzip nicht nur gibt es
rechtlich nicht möglich
doch
aha das ist nicht etwas spät da muss ich
sehen dass ich weiß nicht was ich tun
muss was ist dieser sieg eine pw wischt
[Musik]
zu ihnen auf
mona vetsch ich muss ich zu ihm habe ich
weiß ist dass ich habe euch irgendwie
geil wie schwierig das futter für die
tiere details kinderonkologie radstation
radstation genau und wirklich
mona vetsch drehtag auf trab situation
gut vorbereitet abruf klaus krost das
ist mona mit drin
das duo aus so richtig pflegefachfrau
bestückt kinderspital ich es so richtig
wenn die farbe als extra für christen
sind nicht so streng auf studien genauer
vorgaben beckham parat gemacht für die
dass die allianz mit geld das funktional
ja also das schützen sei verstoße
ja ja burgsee und infusionen wird sofort
live vorstellen
ich kann mir die situation der
krebskranke und wenn sich mit dem mit
denen mit denen schaffen was auch
irgendwie also meint das ist ja das
problem war ich also wenig den reagieren
ich weiß wenn ich jetzt aber ich war
krank
das besagen dass reagiere aber nicht
einfache tore führung dennoch erzielen
ok erweisen sich reden machte
links ist sehr wichtig für ihn wirklich
lebensbedrohliche infektion war für
diese normale schnuppern ist für ihn
nicht kenne
die roten blutkörperchen bismark
medikament von morgen holt matthias
freude bei stoffe zu groß ist schon eine
viertelstunden sieberichs einst weg der
bruder unter martin zellhofer ist sie
mit der neuen situation umgehen
der bauarbeiter zum beispiel extra
basiert
[Musik]
stufe 2 ja und da heißt du es gestern
vor zwei wochen überhaupt wenn erfahren
dass die leukämie wie stark sie noch
erklärt mit den frankfurt zählen halt
schon schlimm
sie wollen den fall an dass daran die
rolle der gläubiger in gefangenschaft in
der aktuellen zu mir gesagt wir sind
später erhält muss auf ihre story schon
irgendwie der matthias dort ganz am
anfang vor dem kampf gegen krankheit der
großteil von tremor und nah und so die
herstellten reich mit musikalischen sagt
rolle
[Musik]
ruhe und stärke von der familie von
maria b druckmotiv aber einfaches
prinzip dass ich der falsche weg
da sprühen einfach der fähigkeit dass
man das wirklich
[Musik]
schreibt station
fertig verlängert
[Musik]
wenn wir da mehr kraft hat gott die tour
wie die zwölf jahre geschehen
eigentlich werde schein in einer
spezialschule für fußball talent aber
den strich dass in die zukunft plant
gemacht sie vier monate in kemer block
noch andere für jede therapie schritt
hinter sich bringt
[Musik]
und das bedeutet ali ist der demokrat
bar wo man mit remo mit dem blog
angefangen hat
denn die armenisch perle wo zum beispiel
videos wie eine tablette und denn ich
bin sehr schwieriges medikamente
schlucken
vermutlich groß wird
tremor bischöfe intensiver
ausgewachsenen will das im körper -
halte bin vorbereitet dürfe die flecken
der junge den kontakt rom mit dem
krebsmedikament gesundheitsschädigend
[Musik]
wirken
du musst in frankfurt promi
verkaufsstellen das fahrzeug zuständig
bin
es ist wahnsinn was zur post und das tut
weh
also was aber letztlich über leitern und
initiativ einzige weg wie wir oder
wirtschaftliche tun oder aber recht
still
[Musik]
femo führt renault und hof nikkei 1
deutlich macht
[Musik]
später am tag bin ich bin viel und sein
ganzer stolz ist lego wichtig ohne
selber zweimal bafin hat gerade ein
intensiver behandlung
[Musik]
wie lange sind die region miteinander
die sechste und jetzt halt wirklich zwei
wochen einfach nur im bett gestanden
aber jetzt gibt es ein lichtblick
[Musik]
während ihr der eigentlich organisierte
stark und nachteilig
jetzt ist die zeit wo man im spital sind
diese suche ich bin immer vom so
friedlich da um ihm kritiker immer da
wenn ja so ja vor allem ich ans kühl das
ist auch wichtig für die plötzlich lebt
man als familie in zwei welten die high
und im spital krankheit diktierte alltag
sieht zwei wochen ist das auf ihrem
markt die als in die familien also
der markt ja ist zweitjüngste fünf
hektar in sechs kinos in die familien im
spital besuchen
das wissen ist aber rantzow
[Musik]
so schwierig und glich so wichtig als
familie in den bus name zustand stück
normalität darin größte sturm immer
wieder schön im moment mit dem hand h
[Musik]
im kinderspital st galler werden jedes
jahr rund 240 patienten betreut zum
glück geht's wieder wenigsten von ihnen
um leben und tod
kind und ältere erlebe dort die ganze
palette von emotionen vor angst über
hoffnung bis glück
[Musik]
nee
für familien mit krebskranken kind ist
auschwitz kinderspital eines spitals
prescht wird für mama papa und kind zum
am tag und die nacht
[Musik]
was für das ist ein guter wert wieder in
firmenblogs of science blutwerte zu
erlernt der form für das bike hersteller
auf die flecken der wischt schwieriger
oder ihr leiblicher das so intensive
[Musik]
auseinandersetzung der kernbotschaft
oder warum er in die rolle jetzt wieder
gemacht hat und das ist mir viel
der markt hat greift die nacht hätten
infekt überreden
[Musik]
vielleicht 3 oder heinz der leitende
arzt der piste gegen machen
und wie ist ihre meinung
und zu ostern hausmacht mit wieder buch
ist gut durchgesetzt dass es schwierig
für uns also buchhaltung geradeaus nicht
gute daten kriegt den ball einfach wäre
wenn mir alles egal ob gesund oder nicht
also oder kein effekt war mein studio zu
sehen
dann können wir sicher machen aber es
gibt gewiss dass wir wirklich nett
findet vorstellt nicht macht es um den
wirt ausstieg sind und jeder in sandwich
bildete sich noch gut daran wie althaus
stellt einen punkt wo man miteinander
reden muss damit sie nicht zahlen aber
für die rede ist wichtig dass man den
hunger stillen
und das schmerzt
martin hitz was ist der größte
unterschied der zwischen erwachsenen
station unserer kinder und ja da gibt es
so viel unterschied weil sich diese
frage ist noch nicht da wo jetzt nicht
lachen der bewegten mit dem mundschutz
war der stars aus europa zurück auf die
wünsche aber die mögliche richtung hier
die möglichst wenig macht sei sie wisse
dass er vielleicht eine wieder ein
medizin ist das wirklich gemacht
als mein vater zum beispiel da hat
keiner mehr will er lange zeit so angst
vor bakterien etwas was mir oben ist der
angst vor keimen und eben wie man sich
auf dem boden aber hole mir viele ältere
missionskritische gute nachrichten
schlechte nachrichten ehrlich wenn ich
ein date oder chöre statistik ist man da
nicht so gern ich bin sicher dass mich
aber auch prinzipiell etwas vier
verfolgt werden teilt der
kinderonkologie welt mit
standardisierten aber der 50
die meisten sind teils tausend augen
italien besetzt anni um das thema und
bürger gemacht
das kind verliere wie carmen umgang mit
dem schlimmstmöglichen geradeaus fliegen
wenn man gewinnt und ihre familie so
lang begleitet hat
[Musik]
marina zeigt mir das buch wo sie die
geschichte drin sammelt
jedem kind die sie begegnet
[Musik]
wenn das wenn das buch erscheint
automatisch erinnerung rufen
erinnerungen und drollige da ist ja nun
sind schon fast fünf wochen seit diesem
schweren tag vergangen das leben geht
weiter
muss weiter denn ich möchte mich und
ganzem herzen danke für viele monate
voller liebevoller und professioneller
pflege für tröstend im optimum für den
würdevollen abschied und für das licht
angeht so schlimm ist denn da man in
betracht so das sind fast überall so
sagt er sich die älteren die sind nicht
weniger dankbar
es ist für mich eher und das ganz
speziell das in ihnen ermöglichen kann
und ab in toni monatelang bedeutet dass
die letzte ehre erwiesen
aber es ist extrem nach gott und
wohlstand so hätten zu und die dotcoms
stock anstands und der schrei und denkst
und bilder
[Musik]
es geht sache auf der station und
schwarz erträge sind
[Musik]
aber es gibt auch linie wurde zufällig
privat laura und ihre mama auf dem gang
klarheit vor zwei jahren hier und tumor
kann also groß ins hirn rey ist gesund
und home zum letzten kontrolle
ja und da hat man sich alternative
und so und krämpfe das heißt für die
älteren lernen die eigene grenze spüren
und zu sich selber ruhigen moment finden
wo man bewusst unser gott zum widerruf
danke am markt casini ältere enthüllt
zum ersten mal seine diagnose zimmer weg
an das konzert von peter auf 15
viel spaß
[Musik]
ich noch
gut dass die da machen
aber ich führe
dahinter
[Musik]
dritter tag im gesamten bescheid warten
so in gang als rom aber zählt ist nur
eine andere patientin mohammad und
ursprüngliches auf die stirn
ich bin monat
schön dich kennenzulernen simona dorf
die station werde da blut rankte
behandelt die von mohammad und seine
beide strecken
dies bedingt einmal im monat mit
frisches blut über und wie dramatisch
die krankheit ist eine auf der foto oder
heinz die bi hat so ist der mohammad zum
ersten mal ins spital wo warst du ganz
kranke viel zu groß und mit ganz viel
produzieren frankfurt wenn er dem
heimatland geht dabei ja monate wird
darin zu sehen bild über um den lehrer
war es nicht liegen
zentriert werden mit mir zu tun und das
video später also mir dankbar
[Musik]
2 hgb und gesicht sich jetzt für für die
route moment nicht viel für jura oder
planen oder wachhunde und bleiben damit
hast du doch genau da hakt bei tag
renault honda strecke dem bundesfonds
angeles für positionen und
wiedereinstellung
unglaublich zwei wuchs ab nach hause zu
schaukeln von möglichst schnell zu der
familie zu sein kollege es eigene zimmer
frühstück
[Musik]
man will ja so gern richtig können
helfen aber als wenig vermag des kampfes
für den markt es gibt jetzt mittag haben
wird
ich stelle mal der manta fahrer in die
nächste nächste gegner dürfte wohl
können an grund- bzw
weiters eine überbuchung durch verklagt
mit dem glück war ich wünsche der ganzen
schule in der werkstatt sieht wenig
scheißtag und das möglichst schnell
wieder zu was wünschst dir ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz recht
[Musik]
die marina ihren mitschülern mit worten
beschrieben und mit ganz viel
bewunderung für trainiere ältere und
steam vom ostschweizer kinderspital wo
sich mit so viel kraft und herz am
schicksal und gestellt als bei männern
nachdem suez neuigkeiten für die kleinen
patienten
ich komme es vor die vom film über ein
buch mit lego es ist es ganz anders
machen
der wechsel wird riskiert beruf
womit schlosser tischler wieder das
machen am liebsten macht
unter markt ja ist zurück in der schule
sein erster tag in der oberstufe camelia
viel glück und kraft in zukunft ihr
machen großartig
[Musik]